hey Kona 360 live this is John Carew
news from Warner Brothers Studios to
Hollywood and I'm currently in the
Warner Brothers archive museum in the
Harry Potter exhibit so let's take a
look first of all I see that alle we
trained it to stay perfectly perfectly
still it's acting like a security guard
for us we also have the fireplace where
Harry receives his letter to go to
Hogwarts he just wants to get an
education and be a good person
that's it we have first edition Harry
Potter books signed by JK Rowling don't
try to take these out of the case
because there's an alarm on it now as
you can see we also have a fantastic
beast section we're gonna get to that
now we're gonna take a walk around and
check out some of my absolute favorite
things from all eight Harry Potter
movies and also fantastic beasts and
where to find them let's go check it out
now currently we're in the Harry Potter
part of our exhibit here at the Warner
Brothers Archive now truth be told the
greatest part about all of this is that
it's all the real deal these are the
real costumes real props used in the
production so really worn by the actors
and the props really used now if you
look all the way over here in Chamber of
Secrets you not only meet Aragog but all
of the descendants of airdog if you have
arachnophobia don't look but real spider
the acromantula we also have a Quidditch
exhibit and aquitted exhibit is not
complete without of course a Nimbus 2000
right here now on this side we have
original Harry Ron and Hermione costumes
truly used in action they verified it
the greatest professors of Hogwarts
we have Rubeus Hagrid we have Professor
Snape we have Professor Dumbledore
McGonagall Professor Flitwick I want to
go to Hogwarts but if you go to Hogwarts
you have to get sorted into your house
right and guys this is the real sorting
hat so you come here this is the
experience where the sorting hat find
out where you belong what's it going to
be
conscientious hard-working a great thing
to be
hufflepuff you supposed to be Gryffindor
my parents are not gonna be happy that's
fine
and you can't talk about Harry Potter
without talking about the Dark Lord
Himself Lord Voldemort if you back up
all the way over here
we even have their wands now remember
the wizard doesn't choose the wand the
wand chooses the wizard we have the
adult Voldemort cool right we got
teenage Tom Riddle we also have young
Tom Riddle long before he is Lord
Voldemort if you guys can see all the
way back here that's Dobby no Dobby
didn't actually exist on set he was
completely done in post-production so
this is like a recreation so that they
kind of had a point of reference most of
the time when they would interact with
Dobby on set they would talk to a tennis
ball random I know now for those of you
guys did a big fan excuse me my dear
we have Sirius Black Gary Oldman here's
a fun tour fact for you Gary Oldman came
and take to take the tour one time and
he was on the back of a cart nobody knew
on the cart who he was which is
hilarious to me the world of Harry
Potter is not complete either without
talking about how artistic and fantastic
and magical the whole thing is and we
even have some of their original
maquettes of like fluffy the three had a
dog the basilisk the Hippogriff and even
these things that don't wind up on set
you still have to create them so that
you have an idea of what your world
really looks like so in my mind this is
a tribute to true artists now we're in
the fantastic beasts and where to find
them section we are standing in the
presence of Oscar winners my friends
take a look behind you this is a
recreation of Jacob Kowalski's apartment
Dan Fogler played that character so you
see the suit that he actually wore to
the bank to try to get the loan you see
his bed the briefcase that sets the
whole thing off
is there fantastic beasts in there who
knows but you can't see the open one
with the biscuits don't try to eat them
they're stale I tried so his apartment
is an absolute disaster kind of like
mine then the distance you also see
Eddie redmayne's character Newt
Scamander he's the man the myth the
legend really the focal point of the
entire movie we have Tina and Queenie
Goldstein I looked for the
dresses in my size that didn't exist now
again great things guys Oscar winners
for best costumes fantastic beasts if
you haven't seen the movie watch it and
then come check all this stuff out now
those are some of my favorite things
from the Harry Potter exhibit but of
course we encourage you to come see it
for yourself so book your tickets go to
WB studio toward calm and lay your eyes
on these things too we'll see you soon